There's more to life than your farm owen he needs
to see that there's a whole galaxy out there
i'm asking you to leave us alone ben i mean
it is he okay you don't care if he's okay
you care if he's showing it's my
responsibility owen i'm his uncle
we talked about this when the time comes he
must be trained like you trained his father
the first time i got to watch
star wars i was pretty blown away
alec guinness as obi-wan kenobi
did some of the most amazing work
to play him as a younger man
i was really excited about it the first
big experience for me was going to the
studio where we shot episode one the
props master brought up a big chest
he looked me in the eye and he opened it up
and i got to choose obi-wan kenobi's lightsaber
this is my favorite one that's the one
yeah so that was a moment i'll never forget
the first lightsaber work we
did was when we fight darth maul
that was an amazing thing to be part of it was
incredibly intricate we were just going so fast
it's quite unlike any other filmmaking i've done
the first time i got dressed up as
obi-wan again it was a special moment
the wonder of star wars and the excitement of
playing obi-wan kenobi it's really quite something
Hello there everyone star wars just dropped a
brand new obi-wan kenobi trailer video so we'll
break it down if you're brand new to the channel
i'll be doing videos for all the episodes be sure
to subscribe to get everything i don't know if
i'm getting into spoiler territory here can i can
i say anything that possibly gets into spoiler
territory here i'm doing a giveaway for disney
plus memberships all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and just leave your favorite moment
from all the trailers so far on the video just
starting at the beginning of the trailer this
starts with a longer scene of obi-wan meeting with
joel edgerton's owen large and then talking about
young luke skywalker they did get all the original
actors to come back so oh and lars beru lars are
played by the same actors from revenge of the
sith it just seems like they haven't included
any scenes from beru lars in the trailers but
they do spend some time on their farmstead with
him watching young luke skywalker even though it
does sound like they don't spend that much time
on tatooine there were a lot of memes posted when
people were like here we go again we just spent
all this time on tatooine and boba fett we spent
all that time during the mandalorian season two
star wars going back to tatooine for the obi-wan
series but then deborah chow the director of the
series who did a lot of your favorite episodes
of the mandalorian did a great job with obi-wan
kenobi episodes said that they only spend a little
while on tatooine at the beginning of the obi-wan
series probably at the end too just to bookend
things like he goes back and eventually starts
building his hut that he lives in because it
seems like he lives in a cave at the beginning
of this series because it's only been about 10
years but owen lars burns him so bad during this
scene like you trained his father like he's
throwing darth vader in obi-wan kenobi's face
like it was his fault it was kind of his fault
not totally his fault but a little bit his fault
it's also a really subtle way to show you how
obi-wan kenobi actually saw luke skywalker at
that young age and apparently he didn't think
of him as much as a surrogate father would like
obi-wan didn't think of him as a son he thought
of him more as a responsibility or an obligation
like a jedi master guarding some really dangerous
threat this is meant to connect with that
conversation that older obi-wan kenobi has with an
older version of luke skywalker during a new hope
where he explains to him why it was so important
that they keep luke skywalker and consequently
his sister leia's identity secret from darth vader
and the emperor a young jedi named darth vader who
was a pupil of mine until he turned to evil helped
the empire hunt down and destroy the jedi knights
a lot of it had to do what was going on
with the jedi inquisitors the jedi hunters
but it was mostly because just in general
what they thought the emperor would do
they felt like the emperor would tear the galaxy
apart looking for them specifically if he found
that they were still alive because their
existence threatened his hold on darth vader
which they eventually paid off during return of
the jedi where the emperor's suspicions become
true darth vader chooses his family over the
emperor tries to kill him obviously there was
all that controversial stuff they did with his
character in the sequel movies bringing palpatine
back at least darth vader killed his physical
body that the emperor was using at that time
but i think the idea here is that over time in the
original trilogy by later in the timeline obi-wan
eventually starts to treat luke as more of a
friend and become a surrogate father figure to him
but at this point in the story when the series
picks up just 10 years past revenge of the sith
he hasn't yet thought of him as family he's more
of an obligation of burden whereas i think they're
really slightly trying to do owen lars some credit
in this clip like he kind of comes off his gruff
in the original trilogy like why did he hate the
jedi so much why didn't he want luke to be trained
your father wanted you to have this when you
were old enough but your uncle wouldn't allow it
he feared you might follow old obi-wan on some
damn full idealistic crusade like your father did
they're trying to use this clip to set up
the idea that owen lars actually did care
about luke and treat him like a son even if he
wasn't getting ready to win any awards for star
wars father of the year star wars full of bad
dads healy's cared enough about luke skywalker
to think that avoiding anything jedi or force
related would help keep him safe or at least keep
him out of trouble but as we all know how wrong
he was trouble finds luke skywalker no matter what
so they're just trying to show you why owen lars
hated the idea of him being traded as a jedi so
much and why it seemed like he didn't like obi-wan
kenobi it's not that he hated obi-wan kenobi but
he didn't want him hanging around his farm making
luke curious about his abilities in the force
but if you think about the original trilogy and
the way that luke skywalker talked about him
before he actually ran into him later in the film
he did know about his existence but it sounds like
around tatooine eventually the locals including
luke thought of him more as old ben but maybe he's
talking about old ben obi-wan kenobi who's that as
if the actual name obi-wan didn't get used as much
or he tried to get people to forget about it
over time so he just started calling himself
old ben so people wouldn't think that he was this
person of interest and it would just kind of help
the secrecy of everything but the really big
thing that the director explained is that during
this series because it's only been about 10 years
when it picks up obi-wan kenobi does not know that
anakin skywalker survived on mustafar he thought
that he died so even though he did know that he
had become a sith lord he was calling himself
darth vader or the emperor was calling him darth
vader he walked away at the end of that movie
thinking that he had died so he's been trying
to protect luke skywalker keep his existence
secret from the emperor because he knows the
emperor is still alive but he doesn't know that
this person walking around in this sith armor
is calling himself darth vader and is his friend
anakin skywalker there's a moment in the trailer
where you see him suiting up in his darth vader
armor and you see obi-wan kenobi in a different
scene seem like he comes to some realization
like oh no i think they're trying to treat darth
vader's identity as this big reveal to him during
the series like wait a minute you're the person
that the sith inquisitors have been talking about
you're my friend anakin skywalker you're still
alive but darth vader will know all about obi-wan
kenobi still being alive and finding him will be
one of his big missions during the series when the
series picks up darth vader doesn't know where he
is but while they're busy with him sending these
jedi inquisitors all over the galaxy looking for
force sensitives he's also at the same time really
looking for obi-wan kenobi but the way that hayden
christensen talked about darth vader during the
series is that he's still building to the height
of his power he's still incredibly angry about the
way revenge of the sith went down about the death
of his wife the death of his supposed children
like he thinks they're still dead but there are
some rumors that during the series he will feel
some pull in the force so he will start to think
about them maybe still being alive but i think
the idea is that he won't truly learn about their
existence until they get closer to the original
trilogy the way they played it in the comics and
this is supposed to be canon is that he didn't
actually learn luke skywalker's identity or his
existence like oh my son is still alive until
right after a new hope they might tweak that
just a little bit he might learn a little bit more
about leia a little bit early on i think that he
doesn't actually confirm leia's existence in her
identity until a little bit after he learns about
luke's identity but one of the other big rumors
is that they do feature a version of young leia at
some point during the series even though i don't
know that she's supposed to be a main character
and for those of you asking about grogu because
he's about the same age as anakin skywalker he's
also still very much alive because he survived
order 66 as we saw during the book of boba fett
episodes right now in the timeline grogu has been
hiding his abilities and forgetting about his jedi
teachings so he's basically off the map so to
speak in terms of them finding people through
the force basically hiding out in the deep outer
rim but we don't know exactly which planet he's on
at this current point in the timeline i'm not
expecting a ton of references to him but i'm
sure there'll be lots of questions about that also
about ahsoka too if you didn't watch star wars the
clone wars at the end of that there was a bit of
a time jump that takes place after he's been darth
vader for a little while they've transitioned to
the new stormtrooper armor he winds up finding
the lightsabers that he had given back to her
earlier in the timeline and thinks that she's
dead so he thinks that ahsoka is dead at this
point in the timeline the way rosario dawson
talked about it though because they're filming
the ahsoka series right now and they're going to
have episodes next year it sounds like there'll be
some sort of flashbacks with hayden christensen as
anakin skywalker or they'll be force ghost anakin
skywalker and present day so during those episodes
there will be some kind of brand new hayden
christensen footage in some form or another
we do have star wars celebration happening next
week that's why they delayed the first couple of
episodes of obi-wan by a day or two just so that
it would be timed with the big star wars panel
that they have with hayden christensen and ewan
mcgregor for obi-wan kenobi we're supposed to
get a mandalorian season 3 trailer on saturday of
course i'll do a video for that too after i do my
episode videos we've already gotten some footage
for the star wars rogue one prequel series i'll
post a link in the description for the trailer
video that i did for that but we might wind up
getting some more footage next week if we do i
will do a new video for it because the she-hulk
episodes are supposed to come during the middle of
august i'm assuming that the star wars rogue one
and or series is going to start somewhere towards
the end of those episodes then after andor is done
that's when the mandalorian season 3 episodes are
supposed to start so that'll either be the very
end of this year like around the same time when
the book of boba fett started or really early
in 2023 like in january at some point i've got a
whole bunch of bonus videos planned for obi-wan
kenobi darth vader all the big characters if you
have any huge questions right now before episode 1
and episode 2 air just write them in the comments
below and i'll add them to my bonus videos
everyone click here for my new obi-wan kenobi
trailer video and click here to learn about
marvel's brand new daredevil series that they're
doing that's right brand new daredevil episodes
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys in the next one!